are you excited by the possibility of a
human
well one the human stepping foot on mars
and
to possible colonization of not
necessarily mars but other planets and
all that kind of stuff for people living
in space
inevitable and never inevitable would
you do it or do you kind of like earth
you know how many how many how many
people will you wait when you wait for
i think it was about when um the the
declaration of
independence was signed about two to
three million people lived here
so would you move like before would you
be like on the first boat
would you be on the 10th boat would you
wait until the declaration of
independence
i don't think i'll be on the short list
because i'll be old by then
they'll probably get a bunch of younger
people but you're it's the
it's the wisdom and the uh the wait
then you are in the classroom
horizontally you i gotta tell you you
are the lucky one so you might be on the
list i don't know yeah
i mean i i kind of feel like i would
love to see earth from above
just to watch our planet i mean just i
mean
you know you can watch a live feed of
the space station
watching earth is magnificent
like this blue tiny little shield
it's so thin our atmosphere like if you
drive to new york you're basically in
outer space i mean it's ridiculous it's
just so thin
and it's just again such a privilege to
be on this planet such a privilege
but i think our species is in for
big good things
i think that you know we will overcome
our little problems
and eventually come together as a
species i feel that we
we we're definitely on the path to that
and
you know it's just not permeated through
the whole
universe yeah i mean through the whole
world yet through the whole earth yet
but it's definitely permeating
you